alors je vous préviens il paraît que
dans ce genre d'intervention il faut
soit déclaré ces conflits d'intérêts
donc je suis complique t vous pouvez pas
avoir idée je travaille pour des gens
qui ne s'intéressent pas suffisamment ou
limite d'autres qui s'intéressent un
certaine marge de manoeuvre pour
attaquer les lillois l'a donc je vous ai
mis par souci d'honnêteté les gens qui
paient et ceux qui ne paient pas ce que
je vais essayer de vous montrer c'est
que le malheureusement aune du début on
va pouvoir l'enlever
on a déjà commencé à l'enlever et qu' il
va bien falloir faire avec
hélas quoi quand on en a envie
c'est clair si vous regardez l'économie
par exemple qui est l'alpha et l'oméga
aujourd'hui de ce qu'on débat qu à
chaque fois qu on compte quand on compte
on est bien content et les oraux c'est
un des trucs beaucoup compté en général
on n'a pas envie de voir des limites
donc vous voyez
voilà des gens qui par exemple pense que
la croissance est un truc de long terme
en voilà d'autres qui vous disent que la
croissance est un truc de long terme
et puis encore d'autres et puis encore
d'autres en fait j'ai passé ce matin
très exactement trente secondes sur
internet a trouvé tous ces trucs là je
pense que si j'avais passé une heure je
vous aurai tous sous les talents nous
rendre à trouver je vais en mettre
15-15 transparent donc en fait les
limites c'est clair qu'on n'aime pas
plus ça dans l'économie qu'ailleurs et
la question c'est est-ce qu'on a raison
de raisonner comme ça alors il ya un
fait dont on s'est rendu compte il ya
quelques décennies maintenant quand on a
commencé à s'aventurer hors de la terre
et qu'on a pu la photographier de
l'extérieur on s'est rendu compte que la
terre était fini mais cette fois on s'en
rend vraiment compte en le regardant
oui c'est une boule est alors non
seulement on s'en rend compte mais en
fait on sait que il ya deux siècles elle
faisait cette taille là et puis
aujourd'hui elle fait la même taille et
bandeau siècle elle fera toujours la
même taille
c'est à dire que la probabilité qu'on
puisse souffler dedans pour la gonfler
comme un ballon et avoir un peu plus
d'espacé malheureusement pas très élevé
donc là on rêve il limite la terre fait
treize mille kilomètres de diamètre
vous allez me dire bon très bien quoi
cela me concerne ça nous concerne un
tout petit peu parce que nous sommes de
plus en plus nombreux à vouloir partager
cette boîte de pétri un peu particulière
qui s'appelle la planète terre vous avez
ici l'évolution de la population depuis
que notre planète c'est depuis que notre
espèce pardon s'est sédentarisée alors
pourquoi est ce qu on aime bien regarder
la population depuis qu'on est
sédentaire parce que ça a complètement
changé la façon dont on vit
avant l'avènement de nomades qui se
baladait un peu à droite et à gauche
et soit dit en passant la
sédentarisation des hommes correspond au
moment où le climat devient stable et se
met pendant dix mille ans a ressemblé à
ce qu'il était on commence à tripoter un
peu fort donc il ya dix mille ans nous
sommes quelques millions sur terre au
moment du début de la révolution
industrielle
on est déjà beaucoup plus nombreux mais
enfin vous voyez que ça a évolué
lentement
et puis là en deux siècles on est passé
à plus de 7 milliards d'individus
alors quand vous regardez ce genre
d'évolution tous les gens qui font des
courbes dans la salle il ya peut-être
quelques-uns beaucoup plus qui
s'intéresse aux courbes et bien vous
vous dites pas complètement sûr que ce
truc là soit complètement durable
c'est-à-dire que l'on veut se stabiliser
sur le niveau haut de la courbe l'appui
on va y rester pendant des milliers
d'années
quelques petits doutes sur le fait que
c'est peut-être comme c'est comme ça que
ça va s'écrire dans le même temps une
des choses que vous savez peut-être
c'est que chacun des bipèdes qui
peuplent la planète s'est mise à
utiliser de plus en plus d'énergie alors
en fait utiliser de l'énergie c'est un
terme parfaitement sains propres
je crois pas qu'une seule personne dans
la salle qui est but du pétrole en tout
cas je vous le déconseille c'est pas
terrible et je vous déconseille encore
plus de mettre les doigts dans la prise
ça vous fera pas à mixer la soupe donc
quand on dit qu'on utilise de l'énergie
en fait c'est très un propre comme
expression où ça veut dire qu'on utilise
une machine qui elle même va utiliser de
l'énergie donc utiliser de plus en plus
d'énergie ça veut juste dire qu'on se
transforme en superman c'est à dire
qu'on a plus en plus de machines à notre
disposition
ici vous avez l'énergie qui est utilisé
par les hommes alors je vais pas vous
détailler sa longtemps je vais juste
vous donner un multiple quand on regarde
la quantité d'énergie commercial qui en
fait celle qui sert à générer du
mouvement ou de la force mécanique donc
j'ai enlevé le bois là dedans qui sert
essentiellement à surfer juste l'énergie
qui sert à générer de la force mécanique
et bien cette énergie a été multiplié
par plus de 20 par individu en un siècle
et demi ce qui est une autre façon de
dire que le parc de machines par
personne le costume d'iron man qu'on
sait tous construits il a été multiplié
par au moins 20 en fait les machines
sont devenus plus efficaces dans le même
temps et il s'est plutôt x 210 autrement
le parc de machines qu'on a aujourd'hui
à notre disposition pour transformer
tout ce qui nous entoure
sur cette planète terre c'est comme
s'ils nous avaient poussé 200 paires de
jambes et 200 paires de bras chacun
c'est un peu ça c'est un peu ça l'idée
on sait tous transformés en shiva
d'une certaine manière et ce qui fait
alors la particularité de l'énergie
c'est que en fait on s'est pas à une
quelconque en jeu ce qu'on achète de
l'énergie c'est ce qui permet de
caractériser le changement c'est ça
qu'il faut avoir qu'il faut avoir en
tête donc l'énergie et du reste les
physiciens ou le répète pour ceux
d'entre vous qui sont passés entre leurs
mains c'est ce qui permet de
caractériser la transformation de
l'environnement de l'énergie c'est
desquels l'énergie qui entrent en jeu
c'est que l'environnement se transforme
cette énergie on ne peut soit dit en
passant qu utiliser celles qu'on trouve
déjà dans la nature parce qu'il ya une
loi très enquiquinante qui a été édictée
par les physiciens il ya très longtemps
que s'appelle la loi de conservation
donc la loi de conservation de vous dit
encore un truc très simple elle dit vous
n'avez pas le droit de créer de
l'énergie dans un système clos j'ai très
très sain dans un système clos pouvez
pas créer d'énergie enfin harry potter
il peut mais vous non donc pour utiliser
de l'énergie
vous êtes obligés d'aller la chercher
dans l'environnement là où elles
existent déjà et vous allez la mettre
dans quelque chose qui sait en faire un
service et ce quelque chose s'appelle un
convertisseur donc en gros pour utiliser
de l'énergie il faut qu'elle soit déjà
dans l'environnement et la mettre dans
un convertisseur alors historiquement on
a un convertisseur sous la main c'est
nous on a une énergie à mettre dedans
c'est la nourriture et on est capable
d'en tirer du travail un peu les corses
un peu moins non pardon j'ai rien dit et
de la chaleur
d'accord c'est ça qu'on est capable d'en
faire historiquement après on se dit
c'est pas mal ce truc là mais c'est
quand même encore un peu limité donc si
on pouvait augmenter ce serait bien
alors on se dit bon on peut utiliser
d'autres convertisseur qu'on a aussi
sous la main par exemple la domestique
et des animaux donc ça veut dire qu'on
s'adjoint déjà des premiers auxiliaires
1 qui vont nous permettre de faire mieux
et plus généralement toutes les énergies
renouvelables que nous avons réussi à
utiliser la force du vent la force de
l'eau etc tous ces trucs là ont été
utilisés long il ya longtemps dans
l'antiquité
et puis il ya deux siècles il ya des
ingénieurs géniaux qui trouvent des
nouveaux convertisseurs qui s'appelle
des machines de métal et à ce moment on
va pouvoir leur donner à manger du
pétrole du gaz du charbon et tout un tas
d'autres trucs et on va pouvoir encore
démultiplié notre capacité à agir sur
l'environnement
donc là vous avez très résumée
l'histoire de l'énergie et des hommes
donc ça fait monsieur d'origine n'a rien
inventé ça fait cinq cent mille ans
qu'on est en transition énergétique et à
chaque fois ce qu'on a cherché à faire
c'est à augmenter notre capacité de
transformation de l'environnement pour
pouvoir faire plus de choses et de
machins parce que nous sommes des
animaux au cumulatif
alors une fois que je vous ai dit ça en
gros la quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise
c'est donc la quantité de machines qui
transforme l'environnement et donc au
premier ordre
la quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise
c'est notre facteur de pression sur
l'environnement au premier rang brrr
c'est vraiment content et l'énergie que
j'utilise ces comptes et la manière ses
comptes et la quantité de transformation
que j'en suis dans l'environnement
ce qui fait que la pression de l'homme
sur son environnement c'est la
population humaine qui a évolué comme ça
fois l'évolution de la consommation
d'énergie et donc ça ressemble à peu
près à ça et donc là on comprend qu'il
ya des sujets qu'il ya deux siècles
n'était absolument pas un problème est
aujourd'hui simplement parce que les
ordres de grandeur ont changé ça devient
des problèmes majeurs alors un problème
majeur c'est quoi c'est un truc qui va
pas durer c'est essentiellement ce à la
définition d'un problème c'est quelque
chose que vous pouvez pas laisser en
l'état c'est à dire que ça finit par se
résoudre
soit parce que vous en êtes occupés soit
à vos dépens mais en général un problème
c'est ça ça finit toujours par trouver
de solution quelque part elle est plus
ou moins maîtrisés plus ou moins
sympathiques plus ou moins agréables
la quantité d'énergie par personne et la
population augmentant la pression
globale augmente et donc les
conséquences de cette pression globale
augmente quelle que soit la conséquence
que vous regardez au premier rang brrr
donc il ya plus de co2 dans l'air plus
d'azoté qui se baladent partout plus de
mercure ici plus de plomb la plus de
soufre plus de ceux ci plus de cela
alors de temps en temps vous avez des
petites corrections qu'on arrive à faire
la marge d'accord donc on arrive à faire
un peu moins de soufre dans les sens
mais au prix de un peu plus d'énergie
consommée dans les raffineries parce
qu'il faut des sulfures et les
carburants
un peu moins de jus pourquoi un peu
moins de trous dans la couche d'ozone
parce qu'on remplace les cfc par
d'autres gaz frigorigènes mais du coup
un peu plus d'énergie pour fabriquer les
gars enfin bref on fait en arbitre les
duisans c'est à dire que supprimer une
nuisance on sait jamais faire ce qu'on
sait faire c'est arbitré pour la
remplacer par une autre qui nous plaît
plus en général c'est ça qu'on fait
alors tout ça on a réussi à le faire et
à considérer que ces plaies pas très
grave parce que il se trouve que dans la
convention économique que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure et qui est celle que vous
avez le plus l'habitude de manipuler
aujourd'hui ce qu'on fait à
l'environnement ça vaut rien ça vaut
rien parce que dans l'économique vous
avez apprise à l'école on vous a
expliqué que les ressources naturelles
était gratuite c'est un axiome de
l'économie classique
vous savez dans l'économie classique les
deux facteurs de production c'est le
capital humain et le travail humain et
le reste s'est comptée comme étant 0
d'accord donc si on a besoin de
l'environnement pour faire de la
production bas c'est parfait c'est
gratuit donc le fait de abîmé entre
guillemets l'actif de départ qui
s'appelle la terre et que mère nature à
fait gratuitement pour nous en 14
milliards d'années depuis le big bang
c'est ça qui lui a fallu à mère nature à
travaille pas très vite donc il faut
attendre big bang une soupe de protons
une première génération des toiles qui
vous fait tous les éléments du tableau
de mendeleïev pissos balade dans
l'espace puis ça fait une deuxième
génération des toiles ça se reconcentre
il vous faut un système climatique etc
des espèces qui apparaissent tout ça
gratuit fait donc on a tous été des
corses en chef
j'adore les corses et donc on attend
simplement que ça se passe que la
recette se base et puis on a raillé puis
on se sert dans ce grand supermarché
absolument génial mais gratuit qui
s'appelle la planète terre et donc quand
on prend dans le supermarché savons rien
d'accord nulle part ça vaut rien alors
on va imaginer si ça valait quelque
chose juste pour que vous avez une idée
vous avez peut-être entendu parler
surtout le cosmonaute qui va vous parler
de la station spatiale internationale en
la station spatiale internationale a
coûté 100 milliards de dollars pour être
construite alors elle sert
essentiellement à monsieur ps qui à
prendre des photos accessoirement à
autre chose alors 100 milliards de
dollars
100 milliards de dollars et là dedans
vous avez pour six personnes je dis bien
pour six personnes
de quoi respirer de quoi boire
partiellement en recyclant vos propos du
rin eu de quoi appeler houston pour dire
que ça la terre s'est produit dans au
puy ça s'arrête là et une pression
atmosphérique d'accord à ce prix là vous
n'avez même pas de quoi faire pousser
des carottes les pattes sol vous avez
pas le bruit des vagues
vous n'avez pas les lapins qui se
reproduisent et vous n'avez absolument
pas la neige qui tombe lieder d'accord
vous avez juste quelques sous ensembles
tout petit tout petit de ce que mère
nature sur terre nous offrent
gratuitement et ça vous coûte quand même
15 milliards de dollars par personne
cette histoire donc moi je me dis bon la
planète
ce que la nature nous a donné
gratuitement en fait il le contest ça
voudrait au moins 15 milliards de
dollars par personne puisque sur terre
on trouve au moins de quoi respirer on
trouve au moins un cycle de l'eau et
puis en fait on trouve beaucoup d'autres
choses dont 15 milliards de dollars par
personne alors là dessus la question
c'est quelle fraction de ces 15
milliards de dollars par personne qui
est le capital de départ je consomme
chaque année avec mes activités
économiques envoyé par exemple pour les
poissons en un siècle on a réussi à
faire disparaître 90% de la bio-masse
dans l'atlantique nord sur les espèces
qui sont commercialement intéressant
c'est pas sur tout mais sur les espèces
qui sont commerçants donc ça bah ça vous
donne un rythme de disparition qui est
de l'ordre du pur sang par an après en
ce qui concerne le pétrole
depuis qu'on a commencé en sortir on a
sorti à peu près la moitié de ce qui
était extractible un peu moins mais
c'est pas grave
donc là vous voyez aussi un rythme
d'amortissement du capital qui est de
l'ordre du pur sang et puis on à
diminuer le stock de forêt on a commencé
à diminuer une partie du stock de sols
cultivables pas une grosse partie
heureusement on a diminué tout ce qu'ils
avaient dans les mines puisque dans les
mines ça se reconstitue pas quand vous
avez une mine de minerai de cuivre quand
vous piocher dedans bas
c'est pas pour autant que le minerai de
cuivre se reconstitue et puis on a
pioché également dans le climat d'une
certaine manière puisque on a commencé à
déstabiliser un système climatique qui
nous allait bien et pour le remettre en
place il va falloir attendre l'après
longtemps donc moi ce que je dis c'est
admettons que ce capital on en consomme
entre 1% et 1 pour 1000 par an d'accord
à ce moment ça veut dire que vous avez
au passif économiquement de chaque
habitant sur terre 15 millions de
dollars par an est d'accord avec moi un
pour mille de 15 milliards ça fait 15
millions à côté de ça vous avez une
production économique qui est contée de
façon classique qui vaut 15 mille
dollars par personne et par an donc en
fait on pense que notre activité
économique nous enrichit et moi je vous
dis bah c'est pas complètement sûr parce
que en fait à chaque fois qu'on produit
1 ont détruit 1000
dit autrement si j'avais à reconstituer
avec mon travail de l'air respirable des
stocks d'espèces etc
en fait je pourrais pas y arriver quoi
donc ce qu'on croit être une bonne
affaire et une croissance économique en
fait une simple un simple changement de
convention vous dis bah non en fait
c'est une décroissance
voilà c'était juste un petit alors il ya
des gens qui ont regardé ça depuis
longtemps
il ya quelques dizaines d'années il ya
une bande de dynamicien des systèmes de
haïti qui avait commencé à faire un
modèle world prix qu'ils ont pu le gard
ise ou popularisée dans un livre qui a
un peu défrayé la chronique à l'époque
qui s'appelait les limites à la
croissance anémique en anglais très mal
traduits en français et dans lequel il
avait fait une scénarisation de ce qui
arriverait à une humanité qui cherchait
à tout le temps croître sur une planète
qui ne voulaient pas croître alors nous
sommes en 1900 ils font tourner leurs
modèles en le faisant partir de 1900
faim partout sauf en 1970 et eux ils
disent je vais commencer par faire
tourner mon modèle à partir de 1900 et
vérifier que le modèle il reproduit bien
ce qui s'est passé donc le modèle vous
dis ben voilà jusqu'en 1970 la
population augmente la nourriture par
personne augmente la production
industrielle par personne etc et vous
avez tout en haut là en bleu les
ressources restantes vous avez un stock
de départ de ressources du pétrole des
minerais etc
évidemment ça diminue un peu avec le
temps
alors en 1970 s'accroît en fait ils
disent même pas plus tard ça va
continuer à croître
vous voyez jusqu'en 2020 il n'y pas de
problème ça continue à croître le monde
va pas s'arrêter de tourner maëlys sauf
que tant qu'on cherche la croissance
perpétuelle sur une planète qui doit pas
croître à un moment le système
s'effondre et vous avez ce que dans un
anglais on appelle au vote shutenko
l'aps c'est à dire que vous allez au
delà des limites de résilience du
système alors vous pouvez dire va très
bien à ce moment je veux pas et donc je
vais me limiter peut-être sauf que
peut-être pas alors dans les limites
qu'on a commencé à franchir
vous en avez ici une qui est passée
totalement sous l'écran radar des de la
presse française dans le dernier rapport
de l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
qui est paru en décembre 2018
vous avez la phrase en rouge que je vous
invite à lire et à méditer dans laquelle
il est dit la production de pétrole
conventionnel est passé par un maximum
en 2008 donc le pic de production pour
le pétrole de conventionner ça existe
puisque ça fait dix ans que c'est passé
alors il reste d'autres types de pétrole
etc
mais globalement on n'est déjà plus très
très loin du moment où ce truc qui
alimentent l'économie mondiale va
commencer à faire des choses bizarres
après vous avez un autre problème à
laval qui a également commencé à se
manifester de manière importante qui est
le changement climatique et là je vais
juste vous donner deux indications sur
ce que ça signifie le changement
climatique ici vous avez une carte de
l'europe telle qu'elle s'observe
aujourd'hui si on supprime pas les
écosystèmes installé pour y faire autre
chose donc le forum des images plus tout
un tas d'autres trucs accessoires
deschamps les routes etc
ici vous avez la carte de l'europe telle
qu'elle existait ya vingt mille ans donc
il ya un bilan on est au coeur de la
dernière ère glaciaire et fait beaucoup
plus froid
évidemment l'europe ne ressemble pas du
tout à ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
d'abord il ya pas de tedx en scandinavie
parce que les scandinaves sont sous la
glace vous avez un glacier de trois
kilomètres d'épaisseur qui occupe toute
la scandinavie
vous avez la même chose au canada pour
constituer ses glaciers il faut prendre
de l'eau quelque part elle a été prise
dans l'océan le niveau de l'océan et 120
mètres plus bas il fait beaucoup plus
froid et beaucoup plus sec donc l'euro
vous avez le toundra sibérienne en
france et
y'a pas de quoi faire vivre le forum des
halles qui manque un peu de
consommateurs à l'époque puisque la
population française est limitée à cent
mille personnes
eh bien le passage de l'europe de gauche
à l'europe de droite qui s'est fait
pendant la dernière déglaciation
correspond à une élévation de la
température planétaire de seulement 5
degrés
on voit une changement climatique quand
on parle de quelques degrés l'élévation
de la moyenne on est vraiment enfin de
parler d'un gros choc
donc d'un côté on commence à manquer de
pétrole de l'autre on se prépare un
changement climatique qui est loin
d'être terminée qui essaiera donc payer
les limites à la croissance
en fait on commence à les voir elle
commence à être saouls de tenait
simplement la part affective de notre
cervelle continue à avoir envie de
regarder les indicateurs qui vont bien
histoire que l'on puisse une minute de
plus monsieur le bourreau de ne pas
regarder la situation telle qu'elle
commence à se présenter mais voilà
malheureusement les limites elles sont
déjà là et pour les plus jeunes d'entre
vous dans cette salle donc ça c'est la
partie très très mauvaise nouvelle
elles vont s'appliquer de manière
croissante jusqu'à ce que vous l'ayez
mon âge et bien plus parce que
malheureusement la terre ne fait
toujours pas 13 8 kilomètres de diamètre
voilà merci